actress Samantha Weinstein has died she
was 28 years old Samantha's loved one
shared the news on her Instagram after
two and a half years of cancer treatment
and a lifetime of jet setting around the
world voicing a plethora of cartoon
animals making music and knowing more
about life than most people ever will
she is off to her next adventure
you say you have no formal experience
um well not as a nanny no
but I've done a lot of babysitting
Samantha's Talent landed on the big
screen in the 2013 remake of Carrie did
you guys see Sue today
I know Chris isn't coming well she's
suspended are you seeing this and in the
years that followed she lent her voice
to multiple animated roles
a wild Tyrannosaurus egg
for her personal life last October she
married her husband Michael Knutson all
this as she battled a major health
struggle something she opened up about
in an essay she wrote over the summer
revealing that just one week before
meeting her future husband she was
diagnosed with a rare form of ovarian
cancer Samantha called her diagnosis the
worst and also the best thing that's
ever happened writing I have more love
in my life and for myself than I ever
could have imagined and I see every day
as a gift